quasiment tous les jours
je viens d'en parler avec le président
avec le
mes shooting
le Premier ministre de la philosophie je
vous laisse la parole
monsieur le Président cher collègue sur
votre une décision le gouvernement mène
le travail pour pouvoir y poster à la
pression extérieure
nous avons créé
une entité pour pouvoir
travailler quasiment 24 heures sur 24
afin de suivre la situation nous
étudions les
décisions et les pas que nous pourrions
prendre dans un certain nombre de
domaines pour pouvoir prendre en
considération
tous les intérêts des entreprises en
tant que première mission que nous avons
à adopter c'est de
et d'assurer le fonctionnement sans
perturbations
de nos entreprises et les textes moments
importantes importantes d'aider les la
population nous avons préparé deux
projets et législatif
qui englobe des mesures correspondantes
il y en a 20 au total nous avons
mentionné les propositions pour
stabiliser les situations pour un
renforcer un certain nombre de secteurs
de nos entreprises
nous avons préparé un projet de loi pour
prévenir la fermeture des entreprises si
elle est propriétaire étrangers fermés
les entreprises de façon non justifiée
nous pourrions pallier cela
la mission principale est de conserver
l'activité et les emplois la plupart
d'entreprise a annonce une suspension
d'activités une suspension de versement
des salaires nous allons donc suivre
cela de tout près
en coordination avec vous nous avons
également préparé des mesures pour
soutenir le domaine des informations et
des technologies d'information notamment
nous allons soulager des taxes
fiscal nous avons proposé des mesures
pour pouvoir soutenir le domaine de la
construction du bâtiment
également nous avons simplifié les
procédures des débat public
nous si besoin nous allons
prolonger des beaux
nous allons également se tenir le
domaine de l'aviation
et nous
allons prendre des mesures de rétorsion
contre toutes les entreprises qui ne
permettent pas d'accueillir des navires
par exemple des navires dans des portes
internationaux
les
mesures
également seront prises pour se tenir le
domaine touristique
nous allons
introduire les avantages et des
préférences
tout ce qui se tiennent et les moyennes
et les petites entreprises
surtout les entreprises qui font partie
du parc
de formation de tout dans environnement
d'entreprises
notamment un palier au manque des
composantes qui ne seront plus livrés en
Russie
surtout nous renforcerons et le domaine
de l'agriculture
les
producteurs à des produits
agroalimentaires pourront obtenir des
prêts
nous allons prolonger également d'un an
les prêts déjà
accordé
les mesures seront également prises pour
pouvoir
soulager le mensuels
sur la votre décision nous allons
prolonger la validité des licences
ces mesures concerneront plus de 120
types de l'essence à savoir
plus de 2000 l'essence
nous prenons des mesures de
réglementation technique
tous les tous les procédures
d'inspection ou de contrôle seront
également suspendu
demande qui ont été appliquer aux
entreprises
notamment les demandes réglementaires
seront également revues
non comprenons que notre économie devra
être transformé pour pouvoir devenir
plus résiliente et nous devrions donner
plus de liberté plus de marge de
manœuvre à nos entreprises le
gouvernement va élargir les
le domaine de la substitution
d'importation chers Vladimir
le développement des mesures entier
sanctions
se déroule de façon
progressive mais
adjoints mais également les responsables
des unités on vous tiendront au courant
de ces étapes je vous remercie
il est tout à fait
compréhensible que la demande de la de
la part de la population
pour un certain nombre de produits
peut-être impactés mais tous les
problèmes seront résolus de façon
progressive la population comprendra
les situations et reste sous contrôle
bien sûr il reste encore quelques
questions en suspens et ainsi je laisse
la parole Antony concernant les mesures
que vous proposez je vous remercie
deux dernières
semaines nous faisons face à une guerre
économique et financière déclarait à la
Fédération de Russie
non
voyons que nos réserves en or et en
devise
sont attaqués mais c'est un préjudice
porté également à l'économie mondiale
nous voyons que les entreprises qui sont
fleurissantes tout à fait fleurissantes
sont obligés de fermer leur portes
il convient de stabiliser la situation
financière il convient d'assurer son
fonctionnement sans interruption pour se
faire nous avons obtenu nous avons
décidé un certain nombre
de choses tout d'abord les mesures pour
endiguer
le départ et des entreprises et la
trésorerie y compris des entreprises
nous allons
rembourser nos dettes à un rouble
en puisant dans les réserves
en or nous allons
attirer les capitaux
[Musique]
dans notre pays nous allons repousser